de forma notável a orapronobis pode
ajudar a tratar várias condições de
saúde incluindo anemia hipertensão que é
pressão alta diabetes e problemas
respiratórios essa planta faz parte das
chamadas plantas alimentícias não
convencionais da sigla punk que costumam
ser tratadas como se fossem invasoras ou
até pragas mas na verdade deveriam
receber mais consideração mais atenção
devido à sua riqueza em nutrientes como
vitaminas minerais e até proteínas entre
as vitaminas encontradas na hora
pronobis estão a vitamina A que é
importante pra saúde dos olhos a saúde
ocular e para fortalecer o sistema de
defesa o sistema imune é riquíssima em
vitamina C que ajuda na produção de
colágeno e na absorção de Ferro em
vitamina K que é essencial paraa
coagulação sanguínea também é uma boa
fonte de vitaminas no complexo B em
relação aos minerais a orapronobis é uma
ótima fonte cálcio Mais até do que a
couve Ela é Rica em zinco fósforo
manganês e magnésio